hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast i have
the distinct
honor and pleasure of sitting with
douglas murray right here
in the studio he happens to be live
douglas
is associate editor at the spectator
author for many publications author of
many books you may know which we will
certainly talk about
upcoming here and he is traveling
in the us now i know your cover story is
something like you're here for espionage
but i have deduced
what you're actually traveling for your
most recent book is the madness of
crowds which
many in our audience will know and
because you wrote the madness of crowds
you've come to portland where we have
taken
crowd madness to the level of high art
you have you're the epicenter uh i
thought that before coming here
but now having been here i'm confirmed
in my initial prejudices
as so often yes um and
yeah it's a thrill to be back in the
united states
i'm touring around the country writing
about
what's going on here at the moment and
uh obviously there's
enough news every 24 hours in america
for an average six months
and um so i've been in a number of
states so far i've got number
more still to go um
uh one mutual friend said to me the
other day
uh i think it's disaster tourism isn't
it douglas
um it's not but i could see how it could
seem like that with the state of your
country at the moment
yes although i mean you do have the
perfect cover story being a journalist
you know disaster tourism is actually
you letting the world see through your
eyes
exactly uh but you know i just came here
as
uh as you know from california i feel
someone that i shot my
bolt i i said in a piece of the weekend
that i thought that california appeared
to be a failed state
but then i came to portland and um i
feel like i stole my own thunder
well thank you yes the state of oregon
it's really the whole west coast i think
right
it all suffers from the same disease why
are the west coast by the way i mean
i'm still well this is a very
interesting question and i've been
involved in some
private discussions along the same lines
and i would say
at least what i'm hearing is that nobody
has a proper bead on what happened
however i do think there's something
missing from the conversation which i
keep trying to introduce but i confess i
don't have the
the precise description of it there's
something about
if you take the tragedy of the commons
as a just sort of general game theoretic
problem
and you try to map it onto our political
landscape i think what it predicts is
that you will have
essentially ruthless capitalists
in some of the most vibrant and dynamic
industries of our moment
who will espouse a
set of beliefs and values um
in public that result in
effectively the collapse of the system
the killing of the goose that lays the
golden eggs
and basically you know it is a tragedy
of the commons in the sense that in a
classic tragedy of the commons
an individual has effectively no power
to protect the commons and has a huge
amount of power over their own
well-being
and so they end up making a decision
that when everybody makes it causes the
commons to collapse
and in this case what it's causing is
political movement in a dangerous
direction based on everybody signaling
to each other and frankly convincing
themselves that they believe this stuff
when in fact they are profiting
from this other side of it and wow are
they going to be shocked
yeah yeah i am
that seems right to me i mean san
francisco being another
base for this um
i'm not i've never been much
committed to the inequality discussion
because i think it's never taken on the
some of the complexities it needed to
and as was oversimplified in an early
stage by certain people
um in the latest iteration but my
goodness uh
the extent to which the actual
inequality problem
exists on this coast is extraordinary
where you have the richest people in the
world
cohabiting with the world's destitute
in such proximity and
they seem to have just got used to it
that's what i can't quite get over
um everyone seems to have got used to
the idea that you can have some of the
world's most expensive real estate
facing a parking lot of
you know people who've got a trolley
well uh so there are a couple
interesting phenomena
one is that i'm sure you are hearing the
same things i am about a huge number of
people who do have that nicest real
estate fleeing
from the circumstance that they have
created yeah
which i think raises very interesting
questions because to my mind
i will be very shocked if in the end the
most powerful people do not end up with
the best real estate it seems to me that
that is an automatic
outcome at equilibrium and that raises
the question if they are
currently fleeing that real estate uh
i wonder if it's not in some sense a
cryptic
and maybe even unconscious renegotiation
strategy
in other words the political regime that
they have ushered in
is now uh generating
perfectly incoherent tax policy for
example that's going to penalize
business out of these places which is
going to cause the economies to come
to collapse and the question is will
the wealthy who fled these pieces of
real estate
be able to demand effectively much more
hospitable terms
in order to bring them back in and make
the economies of these states vibrant
again
i don't know i mean um so much of this
in the us
is just variant state by state in a way
we obviously don't have in the
in uk or indeed in europe you can't flee
across a
boundary and find an entirely different
tax structure or whatever but
um i wonder i mean um new york it seems
to me is going to take a long time to
come back but has the
impetus to do so um like london it's
hard to see
new york not coming back um
i'm curious to hear why you think that's
the case
well uh
before i say i mean i think that
california is it's very hard
and and portland here i just i
i think i said to you last night
why anyone would open a business
in this area i mean why anyone would
open a business almost anywhere at the
moment
is is a pregnant question but why they
would open anything here
is is i mean well it's a question that's
answering yourself they're not
right they're not and there's no plan b
right it was the sort of you know
vibrant libertarian west
that that fueled the place and if you
drive the businesses
out by effectively allowing a small
number of people to demonize
business owners and to inflict arbitrary
damage on them
then what even is you know what are
these states
yeah yeah yeah i i i was on my mind i
went the first time i got here i went to
a um
a rally protest march i don't know what
you'd call it antifa
um blm uh which was
opposed to gentrification was one of his
justifications
where the marchers marched through
residential areas screaming at
householders telling them that they were
living on stolen land
and that black people used to live in
this area and
they've been pushed out something that
wasn't that evident there were
plenty of black home owners in the area
in question
not quite sure how happy i'd be if i
were them that i've been woken up in the
evening by people
bull horns telling me things that
weren't true or accurate
but that seemed to be a fairly uh
ordinary evening in this
in this city um
but you know it seems that it seems that
you have activists who are opposed to
all forms of human betterment
all forms of improvement and
actually don't mind the state they've
created the
the sites in downtown portland seem to
me redland of nothing so much as a third
world city
where people who haven't been here maybe
interested to know i mean
it's much worse than you expect it's not
just that
it's not just the empty plinths i think
there's one statue left standing which
is a world war ii statue i'm hesitant
about saying that because
they might find it they'll yeah it's a
little high up for their um
their gaze but um the
world war ii statue seems to be the only
thing that they haven't brought down
one is tempted to say oh
[Laughter]
um one is tempted to say that um
you know it's it's primarily i think
outsiders think might think it's
primarily about statues but isn't it
it's so many things that have come
together at once it's the fact that
these
sort of history robbed areas
uh also just you know are inhabited by
homeless people
living in tents with sort of food stalls
hanging around outside
i mean it's post-apocalyptic it seems to
me it's it's something that people
should know about
in order to see what happens when you
make this number of mistakes in this
order
well it seems to me that you're pointing
something out that i think in some sense
only you can point out
um maybe you don't even realize you're
doing it but
because of the way covid has intersected
with the george floyd protests and riots
and what
has happened to portland the point is in
general those who are reporting on what
took place here
are from here and we are held to a
particular absurd
standard where you know i have been
absolutely
diligent about not portraying portland
as on fire
because it isn't but that we have
nightly riots
is um a
reliable fact and it has a very distinct
implication
and the so in some sense you coming here
as a visitor
and seeing it and saying it's actually
worse than you expect when we are
constantly told
if we mention the riots that we are
portraying something false
which is obviously not the case no i
mean
this is this is a maddening hostage
situation
for a population to be in to be told you
know it's not
literally burning down all the time so
how dare you say portland is burning
um i've seen this as you have in
areas before i don't as in this
rhetorical move
oh yeah you know don't why are you
saying things are so bad
bad things continuously happening does
not equal a bad situation
right you know just because you have x
problem every day doesn't mean you have
x problem um i i don't think
there's i i mean like you i've managed
to travel very widely around the world
in my life and it's a
great honor and privilege of my life
um but it means that i do have some
reference points
what people in poland are living through
is not normal it's certainly not normal
in a first world city
there are places in the world where i've
seen
similar destitution it's less by choice
than it appears to be here and a certain
element of it
does appear to be by choice um but
you have to go to you know
parts of south africa bits of
india and elsewhere to find the
normalization and acceptance of
homelessness at the level it is
and then you have these extra layers on
top as you say the covert
layer is is one that seems to strip
everything back and
obviously that my own country is
suffering very deeply from this and the
economic consequences in all of our
countries are just
unfathomable at the moment but but you
have this
this extra virus layer of of people who
think that it is perfectly normal
to engage as a full-time occupation in
assailing the state and any
front face of the state as if it is
a fascist entity which needs to be
pulled down entirely
and the people who say that that's um
[Music]
that some minority or something
it clearly is a minority it's quite a
large minority on occasions clearly in
july and august in the city
it was it was a significant minority
it's dwindled a bit now
but it is not normal for drivers
to to be prevented from going down
streets because they're blocked off by
pseudo-power and military groups as it's
happening in this city
it's not normal that the police would
not be visible
for hours in center of the city at night
and that instead
militias that are self-appointed
barricade those areas off and the police
don't go
none of this is normal let alone as i
saw the other night
crowds of antifa activists
trying to
basically storm or something similar a
federal building
in order that well what do they want to
do burn it down
obviously and they get into this
running battle with federal police
which i saw myself and they set fires to
things and
then tried to provoke the police to
attack them
and that again i mean i've seen running
battles before i just haven't seen them
in a first world city that's said to be
at peace
now this is uh i gotta tell you it's
actually quite refining to have you
visit and say this because we have had
um you know nancy rommelman for example
who
uh used to live here and came back to
report on the situation
but um you are the person farthest
afield to come in and look at it and to
the reality check of just hearing you
describe what it is that we see and what
it is that we are in some sense
stalemated in our ability to even
describe it to the world is very
um heartening by the way one other thing
on that if i may sure
um it's uh it's i mean
clearly those politicians who are in
charge of the portland area feel no
shame and feel no responsibility for the
admiseration of the people over whom
they're meant to
govern ordinarily one would try to shame
them but clearly
we're in a in a mechanism where that
that wouldn't work nevertheless i think
it has to be stated
again i have never been to a place
where it is commonplace and acceptable
for people to graffiti
and put up signs everywhere saying that
a journalist should be murdered
absolutely nowhere nowhere i have been
to
totalitarian countries where journalists
are
at this kind of risk i have been to
closed societies where journalists fear
that they are at such a risk
but i have never been again to a first
world free democratic society
where the local authorities allow
paramilitary organizations to demand the
killing of a journalist for the crime of
reporting
and to have such calls everywhere
in the center of the city and i am not
as people
see in the coming days i post some of
this we'll see i'm not exaggerating this
that i mean we can we can name one but
uh
um but the journalist i'm obviously
thinking of his
name is scrawled over walls and over
monuments in the city
sure i mean he's he's been a guest to
this podcast okay so yeah so andy no
andy now um who's done more than anyone
to report on what
these groups are doing um i knew how
much a risk you'd taken i knew how brave
he'd been
the extent to which he um
has been braver than almost all the
journalists from this state put together
in bothering to report what so many
journalists just think
is not worth reporting to walk through
the center city and to see
uh um say on the world war ii monument
on the
massive walls downtown
calls to kill andy no in big letters
stated as such it's not free speech that
is incitement to murder
and the authorities here don't care
about it at all
they clearly don't care about it or
they'd have done something about it but
again as i say
ordinarily one would make that point and
hope to shame authorities into doing
something
to for instance take down calls to
murder a journalist
in the city but the authorities here
have let so much go that merely
encouraging the murder of journalists
for the crime of reporting is
is a comparatively minor issue for them
to address
well i want to adjust one thing in what
you said i of course resonate with it
across the board with one exception
which is
i don't think these politicians are
insensitive to shame
i think some of them are in other words
we have a mayoral candidate
who i believe may be insensitive to
shame
but our current mayor i don't believe is
insensitive to shame in fact i believe
he is being
um puppeted using his shame
it is his compassion that has been
weaponized against him right
and so in in effect again i think this
comes down to the game
theory which is you have a tiny number
of people
some of whom are shameless who are using
shame as a weapon
and they are arguing they have been set
up by a political
um narrative in which one side is
understood to be
evil literally evil and the other side
is understood to be
the force that holds back evil and so
therefore anything that maps
onto the side that is evil is not
deserving of protection
yes this is the this is exactly the
dynamic that unfolds when one
uh population goes to war against
another it dehumanizes absolutely
and so andy noe falls outside the zone
of protection
yeah of the authority
and this is frightening and i'm i'm i
fear that the comparison you're saying
you've seen these things but you haven't
seen them in a first world city
i think many of us who are paying
attention fear
that we are going to square that circle
by ending up
effectively a third world country yeah
yeah yeah yeah and
you're very close to it in this city
very close to it i mean um
uh i went to a restaurant the other day
cafe
much recommended uh which uh just uh the
day before two days before it had
its uh the people that anti-fire
activists
blm actors whatever these ones are now
calling themselves
uh fired uh shots through the windows
uh because the uh cafe in question has
first responder photos on the walls
that is you know photos of firemen
coming out of flames
um and you know a female
you know cadet in army uniform um
it's a cafe run by a black man who
is um
is obviously proud of the fact that
people in this country have historically
and today put themselves in the front
line to protect the population of the
united states
and this is seen as so reprehensible by
the local
well as i say i would say fascist
militia
groups that he is that he has to have
that he has to have the situation where
he's got boarded up windows because
people have fired rounds of live
ammunition
through the windows of his cafe again i
mean
i've seen that in the middle east yeah
okay i've seen people in the middle east
intimidate business owners by firing
live ammunition at their properties
i've never heard of it happening in a
first world city
with the follow-on that the authorities
aren't interested
the authorities which are perfectly
capable of shutting this down yes any
day
of anywhere absolutely this is
effectively being
sanctioned by allowing it to happen yes
um
so
i'm always with you caught in the
following bind and i think
we uh i'm hoping we can address it
productively but i
confess i don't know where this goes you
are nominally
a conservative right i am very much a
liberal and i
know precisely what i mean by that
i find you i don't even want to say
paradoxical because i don't
think there's any paradox in it but as i
accused you of the
first time you were on the dark horse
podcast
you there are things you say that strike
me
as more more usually heard
from what used to be called a bleeding
heart liberal right
um no but i think this is i think this
is marvelous and i must say my audience
is apparently very confused about me at
the moment
and i think actually i've threaded the
needle i'm told by the person who mans
the uh
the email account that goes with this
podcast that there are
many i rate people who appear to be
perfectly divided over the question of
whether i
am cryptically in favor of trump and
supporting him
or have the worst case of trump
derangement syndrome they've ever seen
so anyway somehow somehow nobody can
figure out
where anyone belongs and i think you
speak to something that is not
um is not commonly seen
which is i hear in what you say
and frankly douglas i see it on your
face when you say it
you are um
you actually feel the pain
of what is being lost and those who are
being
uh run over
roughshod um and
you know you're trying to do something
about it by spelling it out by
describing it in ways that other people
haven't
seen it but here's the question
i i'm living in portland with my family
i am watching the political
scenario descend from bad to worse
right we have a completely ineffectual
mayor who has allowed the situation to
develop
and he is actually if the polls are to
be believed behind in a race
with a antifa sympathizer
yep so there is no
good option on our ballot with respect
to escaping this dynamic
and this has been a long-winded way of
getting to the real question which is
there is something to be said about the
interaction
of liberalism and conservatism and i
have said many times that there is an
important tension between these that
each side keeps the other side honest
that they are both necessary
i'm sure you resonate with that but i
think there's another level we have to
go structurally speaking
um you stop me where i go wrong
the magic of the west
is the product of
liberal ambitions restrained
by conservative discipline yes
you take either of those away if you
take the liberals away you don't get
there
yeah right if you take the conservatives
away you
go off into crazy town i would
i would uh i'd add a thing that which is
i think
quite often people find it um hard to
work out why
something like the dichotomy that used
to exist in america exists in my country
does exist
in almost exactly equal portions who
wh why isn't it the case that i know the
left wins every election
um or the right wins every election why
do we have this back and forth
and one of the things i think people
don't say often enough is that
it's because the line goes through all
of us
you know we all have
a liberal in the american sense leftist
and
conservative instincts on a range of
issues and quite often on the same
issues
and that this very fine balancing act is
one that we know in our lives on
so many issues i mean uh day to day you
know i i want
this thing and yet i know i need to
buy things that i can afford and
you weigh it up in your cat should i
borrow money to get this thing that i
want
the the left bit of the brain away says
i'd like the thing
and the right wing bit of the brain says
but you can't afford a thing you
certainly shouldn't get into debt in
order to do so we know that
another obvious one is uh i like
this thing whether it's alcohol
food drugs whatever you might want this
thing
and another bit of your brain says yes
but is it going to be good for you and
and so
we know the the restraining impulse
because we all have it
every hour of the day um particularly
after 6 p.m in my own experience
and yet politically we don't think in
these terms
often enough that that yes you may
you may want these things which whether
it may include
hard proposings you may want all of
these rights you may want all of these
liberties
but another thing has to come in that is
a restraining impulse on those things
because we know what happens and again
this city knows what happens
with an unrestrained impulse in politics
as in our personal lives which is that
you enter the realm of complete chaos
and this seems to me it's always seemed
to me the dichotomy that exists in
politics and it's why there's a roughly
you
know
49 51 the situation or in my country a
48-52
divide that that exists and that there's
nothing that
wrong with it in fact it's a perfectly
fine
contest unless as you say one side
completely disappears
and you know i wouldn't want to live in
a society where
all of the restraining impulses
that can exist on the right existed
because among other things would mean
your society was
closed to new proposals
that may well necessarily correct things
you should have corrected before and
haven't got around to
so i wouldn't want to live in a society
where only the right existed
and i wouldn't want to live in a society
where only the left existed where the
restraining impulse didn't exist and
that seems to be one of the things that
you have here
and it ends in this urine stenched
history-less pathetic people
wasteland where you know
look at the the arrest photos every
night in portland
the photos of the people in those in
those mug shots
show the the consequence of an
unrestrained life that is a life where
you think you are free and you are
living in total chaos
where you live in a disordered life with
a disordered brain with disordered ideas
of your society and disordered ideas of
yourself
totally agree now so anyway
i do this is great so far i think i
think we are getting to the
the heart of the matter right so i will
take a certain amount of flack
for having a congenial conversation with
you because you being a conservative
are taken to be some sort of a stain on
my liberalism by the way
may i make a quick interjection there
only please
i hope people notice that it never
happens the other way around
so interesting it used to in the u.s
right it has not in some time yes when
did you think it did last
um 80s
right okay i i um yeah you make the
reference because i think the people
should deduce a
number of things from this uh
if somebody said to me you know douglas
i can't believe you sat down with brett
i mean he
is a leftist nobody say it i wouldn't
say oh my god i had no idea he was like
i i i'm so sorry i mean i had no idea he
had all these views and and he votes
for candice i might not vote for and and
um and i'm so sorry and if they said
douglas you are going to be
excommunicated from the right
i'm going to say who the hell are you
i'm gonna i mean i i it's such an
unfathomable thing to me
the only explanation i've ever had for
why this happens the other way around
is the writers stopped being a club of
affiliation and the left is a lifestyle
choice
i mean everything in your i'm not saying
in your case but in in
leftists many left is fine everything to
do with their identity is tied up with
their left-wing
views and left-wing activism and
therefore being um
excommunicated from the club actually
does matter
i can see i mean my left his friends who
who do get excommunicated and a lot of
them do
um feel it very deeply because they
think i've spent my life on the left
how could i not be wanted by my tribe i
personally
say there's not a tribe i would want to
be a part of that pulled that move
absolutely absolutely agree with you and
there is you know there's some tiny
group of us
on the left who are neither fish nor
foul at this point because the fact that
we are
left in our belief structure does not
mean that we are left with respect to
who will speak to us right so it's
become this very
uh bizarre paradox yeah but
i will say just in passing
i find nothing odd at all about
being a
very liberal person who
has no trouble talking to you i find
what you say is sensible
interesting frequently raises
points that i need to think about in
fact i think this is almost the
expectation
right it's not a paradox in fact there
are no paradoxes i've said you know
all true stories must reconcile
the resolution that makes it not a
paradox is
all systems that work work based on
dynamic tension all complex systems
including the body the body is
absolutely riddled with these things
that manage your temperature your ph
every single system even you know the
motion of a limb
is tension between two systems that pull
in opposite directions
so to the extent
that i see the possibility and in fact
the necessity
of fixing the problems with society and
making it better
i know that the tension on the other
side is what makes that plausible
right so you know i i think the problem
is we're confused over the center
right um centrism has a very nasty
connotation i
i admit to feeling this personally i
don't like centrists
right because they're tepid but
i do think we need to meet in the center
and that
two people who are you know in effect
what i'm saying is
i think you are a kind of specialist
that you see the aspect of the system
that requires a conservative bent to see
it well
and you see it with a great deal of
precision right
by virtue of that you may have you know
just as
eyes that are tuned today aren't so
great at night
right that specialty may make it harder
for you to see things of the opposite oh
yeah
yeah sure and therefore there's
obviously
um value to be had in that discussion
and that discussion takes place in the
center yes not necessarily with
centrists
obvious example is things to do with
compassion
um compassion is a it can be a noble
instinct it isn't always
because it has to be balanced out with
uh well what would you
balance compassion out with um
a sense of having to pay sometimes
so this is this is one of the things
that i see very clearly
about you is that um
people mistake a sort of
unbridled niceness for compassion
yes that's not what compassion is right
a parent
that does a good job with children is a
parent that knows
how to meet out discipline how to set
goals that are difficult to attain but
achievable right it's not like whatever
you want honey right it's something much
more complex than that as a and
empathy the the overriding urge in our
age
to be empathetic is again i mean it's
one that requires serious balancing like
i
i in in some sense one has endless
empathy with people
except it can't be endless because we
have to do other things with our day
and if i just had empathy all the time
i'd melt in a puddle right you'd be
paralyzed by it
um and again it comes back to this thing
of
do you pay for when you screw up
and the answer has to be yes now
the balance is clearly to what extent do
we
forgive mistakes
and how far can the mistakes go before
actually something else kicks in another
mechanism
again coming back to this city um uh
mingling in the antifa protest the other
night against the ice facility in
portland
these reprehensible
mainly young mainly white people are
sailing a government
facility were desperately trying to
provoke the police
to be violent against them in order
that then they could say they had been
treated badly
by the way i might take some flack for
this but the
extraordinary restraint of the
federal police who i saw in action was
remarkable to me and because everybody
has
understandably spent part of this year
fixating on american policing
maybe this needs to be said in terms of
balance as well
that seeing uh seeing men
of every race racial background
in federal police uniforms being taunted
and threatened in the american street
by people screaming at them through bull
horns
that they were not just fascists and
nazis but
uh what was what one young woman was
screaming uh repeatedly you know
your family hates you your children will
be will hate you
you never see your family you're
destroying
this country and and and all this
something and
and these agents they they happened to
clear me out of a
bit of the protest i was in and um and
they did so with extraordinary
politeness
considering that it was nearly the
middle of the night
we were all wearing black face coverings
they
couldn't have seen who had arms and who
didn't
um and uh they very
politely albeit with heaven heavy
weaponry
um got us away and cleared people out
and i
thought as i've thought i've seen videos
of certain american particularly black
american policemen
being taunted and insulted
and provoked by anti-factivists and
others
i uh think the restraint that these
that these men are actually having to
exercise
is nothing less than remarkable
but these people on the streets of this
city
are clearly people who need a restraint
and they need to be stopped
from hurling projectiles
from smashing up business after business
to the extent that
large portions of this city have more
shuttered businesses
with boarding over them than open
businesses by a very long way that
this has come about because nobody
stopped them throwing the damn rocks
nobody told them you can't start to set
fires in buildings and in the streets
and get away with it
this doesn't seem to have happened the
restraining mechanism has totally broken
down and by the way
the fear of that and this is a
legitimate fear of the decent part of
the left is
what if the overreact what if the
reaction is an overreaction
which i must say i haven't seen it yet
but that is inevitable oh yes i mean i i
thought it myself this week each time i
saw these
people i thought you know the ignoble
instinct kicks in i wish somebody would
beat the crap out of you
just beat the crap out of you you know
uh appointing yourself
to just destroy private property running
around looking
hoping that somebody lays a finger on
you in order that you can pretend that
you are now oppressed
when you have been rampaging through a
town and a miserable its inhabitants yes
you know
terrorizing citizens in their own homes
people you don't know you have no idea
what they think or want or anything
but as i say i mean it's an ignoble
instinct but i would hope that it would
settle somewhere
again it comes to meeting in the middle
it would settle somewhere in terms of
just
ordinary damn policing and the exercise
of justice
that means that people who do this sort
of thing get arrested and go to prison
right which is so
okay this has unfolded we have a mayor
who for reasons i cannot quite fathom
has misunderstood that there is
nothing he could do to find favor with
these people
he has effectively let them do what they
do
and they think he's a sort of alt-right
whatever his opponent said
they see him as just another version of
fascist
right yeah so the right reaction from
his perspective if he
saw with any clarity at all would be
well there's no yeah i'm not going to be
able to woo
over that percentage of the lunatics
right nor should i want to therefore
you know doing right by the majority of
the population of portland
uh is the obvious thing to do but you
know
what is he being threatened by in this
election it's not something from
the right where people are calling for
law and order they're so
busy virtue signaling to each other that
they're actually in danger of electing
somebody even crazier yes
that's that's why i say that i mean i
have less hope for this place than other
places i mean
it would seem to me obvious that new
york although it's a bit beleaguered at
the moment
um like london and there's a lot of
shuttered businesses
and a lot of things are not going to
come back fast nevertheless in terms of
law and order and things
uh um it seems clear to me maybe it's
because of the accumulation of capital
well-off people or businesses just they
can't allow to go down
the market and much more whatever the
reason i i think that new yorkers will
will be voting in a right-wing law and
order mayor
very soon uh though they will get a
giuliani-like figure because new york's
been
through this cycle several times in our
own life yes it has
and i and i would expect new yorkers to
to do that
because um they're not going to put up
with you know
rapes on the subway and killings in the
streets
on a regular basis without voting for
somebody who knows how to sort some of
their stuff out
and that then therefore and they will
deserve the return of their city
but if this is it comes back to the
cross
at some point the people in portland
have decided not to do that
or it hasn't thrown up people willing to
do it and so
at that stage the people of the city
bear responsibility for what has
happened well as i keep saying and
nobody
seems to to respond to it the way i
expect
they're going to get what they deserve
unfortunately we are also going to get
what they deserve
absolutely absolutely um which i i can't
believe this is being allowed to happen
but you know it also the
the way the left and in particular the
democratic party under the
corrupt rule of the dnc is playing this
[Music]
they have created a legitimate argument
in favor of trump yes right there wasn't
one
and what they've done is they've created
one by leaving the federal government as
the only potential
restraining force um against this
insanity and you know i
i sure don't want to see that happen on
the other hand what happens if the
democrats
you know take the white house and who
knows what in congress and
uh you know what does protect portland
from
this nonsense the the um
the thing's been on my mind uh in recent
days has been that
so much this seems to come down to a
fundamental misapprehension about the
nature of the society that you're in
uh as i see it i mean i don't see that
there's no white supremacists in america
there must be some but my gosh are they
pushed to the margins
and um i think that a white supremacist
group
doing what so-called antifa are doing on
a regular basis to an american city
would have been
not tolerated from day two right uh
and rightly so um what seems to
have occurred the image i can't get out
of my mind is that it's like a magic
lantern trick that's occurred in this
society that
in this area um that you know there's
this like tiny
residual reprehensible
neo-nazi white supremacist
you know people and
the some somehow the society has put a
light behind
that and it's blown up onto a wall into
this huge
monster against which these people
in portland and the surrounding area are
are fighting
and the politicians unfortunately
have encouraged this perception they
haven't said
you're totally wrong right the american
police
may have all sorts of things that need
to be done to improve them but they are
not the nazis
and um you know there may be injustices
in society but
we are not a reprehensibly unjust
society that requires burning down in
order to get through the furnace to some
better state they haven't done that
they've been willing nancy pelosi did it
well that's the thing they've been
willing to make people believe this
thing because they think they're going
to be advantaged by it
yes individually they are advantaged by
it and what they are doing
is uh upending the
structure on which we all depend right
each person is serving their own
individual interests
at cost to the structure that
uh undergirds everything yes and
um so there's so many things
ready to go here but um one let's just
say the cinquanon
of white supremacy right if you were to
define that term in
any reasonable way it can't be
that you are um allowing
something that advantages white people
to continue
a white supremacist would have to be
rooting for that
yes and so if we take that that a white
supremacist
must be rooting for white people above
others
right then the answer is exactly what
you said those people are vanishingly
rare
they weren't always vanishingly rare
they're not non-existent
but you're right magic lantern they've
been projected onto a wall
at huge size and then everybody has said
okay you know who
who is in league with that thing it's
everybody who isn't on our side yeah
right which creates um
basically a race to the bottom um that
we are now
seeing the the product of but i have the
sense
well one other thing i want to say the
the thing about
the graffiti on the wall calling for uh
andy noe to be killed um
the shots fired into the cafe
uh owned by a black man who would dare
have first responders uh on his wall
this is a matter of policing
narrative right why is andy noe
the target of their ire because andy no
makes it impossible to sell the story
that you have people protesting racial
injustice on the streets of portland
and facing a fascist crackdown from the
federal government
you cannot believe that if you just
simply pay attention to the video
that andy know puts out on his channel
yeah right yeah
you know you could say all sorts of
things about it's not a complete picture
whatever you want but
the fact is you can see what it is yeah
right those things are taking place
likewise a black man who is running a
successful business
doesn't hold truck with any of this uh
you know white supremacy is everywhere
nonsense
is very inconvenient to the narrative
and the result
is you know we've said it before but you
know
yeah you've got the police are
standing back and allowing this to
happen you know having been
restrained by the municipal authorities
you've got
you know basically paramilitaries
enforcing their
their own laws this you know this this
was evergreen blown up to
uh major american city size yeah um
so the
i guess the question is a is there an
example
of a society that has
gone this far in the direction of one of
these
uh nominally justice oriented
utopian
revolutions that has turned around as a
result of
reason
that's a very hard question to answer
maybe people can answer in the comments
underneath this video but
one
the problem is is is is the combination
of
of factors here that's what disturbs me
um you have the
the imminent decline in living standards
of everybody in society
overlaid on top of a number of existing
problems
including a misperception about the
nature of the state they're in a belief
that they are engaged in a life and
death struggle against an
if not non-existent then very mindly
existent
enemy the um
a lack of purpose and meaning in
individuals as well as the wider society
that means that any cause
is worth getting on board with if it'll
give you purpose
in your day and in your life um
i mean i could go on the pro the problem
is all of these
things it seems to me and and
it it's perfectly easy
to see how and it's happened many times
um
an immiserated city can be brought back
from
the brink of poverty and made into a
vibrant and dynamic
financial proposition again and that's
that's happened in all of our countries
repeatedly that's a city though
right um the
the number of things that need to be
corrected here
seem to be so significant in number that
that i don't at all blame as in
california my friends who say right
that's it i'm off
um and the more that happens the more
all you have
left behind other people who either
can't move
which is apart from things those who are
less financially
you know fluid flexible
uh that means the poor just can't move
um and and those who really do think
that the wasteland is what they want to
inhabit
but um there is
it's yeah it's hard to i can't think of
anything that that comes around from all
these factors simultaneously no
yeah that that's worrying me um quite a
bit
so let's just i think this is
this should be obvious um i'm sure it
will be to you
but i think it needs to be said because
i never hear it said and it seems the
core
you have a society that
generates a huge amount of well-being
that well-being is not well distributed
i do not mean to say it should be evenly
distributed but it is not well
distributed it's not efficiently
distributed with respect to producing
the kind of incentive that you would
want you know a diet in the wool
libertarian ought to want opportunity
better distributed because it results in
more people
discovering more things that serve us
collectively right
so we've got a society that creates a
hell of a lot of wealth
it's not fairly distributed it's not
well distributed
the revolution that we are watching
begin has misunderstood
the difference between um
the uh noise in the way and you know
there's a lot of signal in how it's
distributed but i would argue there's
even more noise in how it's distributed
they've misunderstood the basic fact
that their lives will get
much much worse if the engine that
creates the well-being that is unfairly
distributed
is turned off yes right yes and so the
point is
if you just wanted to talk about
absolute well-being
and you are compassionate for all sorts
of people who have less than they ought
to or who were given tools that are less
useful than they might
right if you want those people to be
well off
you are about to hurt them
egregiously by turning off the engine
on yes we are all yeah yeah yeah um
[Music]
yes this is the misunderstanding that
emmanuel kant
describes the the famous dove analogy
you know the
the the candidates dove is the the
the dove flying in free air may make the
mistake of thinking that the air under
its wings is the thing that's holding it
back
[Music]
yeah that's it um and may imagine that
in free air it could
fly further faster
yeah right in a vacuum yeah and
that's what these activists and
a significant portion of the american
public now make the mistake of thinking
they think
and we've had we have this in my own
country as well although thankfully the
ballot box it keeps being seen off
but uh there are significant numbers of
people in our societies who think
if i could only stop capitalism
not not a form of capitalism or or some
extreme
uh versions of capitalism or capitalism
gone wrong or bad capitalism or anything
more
but capital the capitalism uh
the exchange of of services
financial incentive products all this if
i could just stop that we would be
fairer
and it's incumbent upon anybody who
knows history as anyone
as well as anyone with eyes to say the
situation you are dreaming of that you
think will allow you to fly
further and faster will make you plummet
yeah
plummet and the people with the most
capital from the capital system
capitalist system
will be able to leave your benighted
results right but most people will not
he will collapse on yeah all of those
who don't have the meaning i mean
this is this is obviously the case with
property in all of our
countries at the moment i mean once you
see the
differential between average wages and
average property price
go to five times or something you know
and much
more and places like san francisco i
mentioned earlier
far more of the average salary to
average property price
you end up in this system where you
think
all the corrections you can see are
catastrophic
what happens in a society where the
average cost of a home is a million
dollars or 1.5 million dollars
and the average wage certainly isn't
that but you have the asset
and there's no one to buy it from you at
some stage
we get into this we we get into this
realm of you know all of the
all of the words for what happens
after that are terrible right you know
collapse
um yeah good luck killing field
right um so
a friend i'm i didn't clear it with him
so i can't i can't use his name but a
friend posed a question
the other night in a clubhouse
discussion
whether there were any new
ideological movements or whether we were
just simply
rehashing all of the familiar ones
and it struck me as a very good question
very good question
i do think i do think i have something i
would describe as roughly new but let's
put that to the side
for the second for the most part okay
but for the most part we are rehashing
prior ideas and dressing them up in new
ways and
you know tinkering around the edges but
here's here's the
reason that i think that is likely to be
true
the fact is what we
have is a description of a roughly
optimal system
liberalism in its sort of theoretical
form
is the right answer yeah right a system
that
provides liberty that distributes
opportunity
evenly right that
is the ideal form now we're nowhere near
it
but the point is the reason that we are
not looking at new ideologies
is that we're really talking about the
corrective for the degree to which we
fall
short of an ideal that we have already
discovered
right yeah and
i think this is really important because
i think we're just fighting over the
wrong
thing right i think even you know the
idea
really ought to be you know we have to
find our way to fixing the remaining
obstacles to our actually living by our
liberal principles on which almost all
of us agree
right and as we get there
the conservative force that prevents us
from
having utopian ideas beyond a
functional liberal society that is very
fair
right that force has to prevent us from
seeking some place that doesn't exist
beyond
that state
[Music]
i would add one thing to that i agree
with most of that but the
um i think we never did take enough
account of the problem of people who
didn't find the state you're describing
as actually optimal as we regard it as
being
so i don't think we're as far off
but i think i think in some sense that's
like
talking about people who've never
traveled
to a nation and their opinion in other
words
you know and this goes back to those
those
mugshots that you were talking about i
do have the sense that one of the
patterns of history
that we see is there's something very
valuable about
a meritocratic system meritocracy
is uh a magic ingredient it's not
sufficient
on its own but it is a magic ingredient
to the achievement of things
and um that that thing
to the extent that feedbacks are bad
that unfairness is badly distributed
certain people end up poorly placed
to function in a meritocracy yes yes and
eventually if those people
are large enough in number they rebel
against the idea
of meritocracy uh
yes that's right and um uh
yeah if you end up
putting an un well and unwield the
emphasis
on that aspect of the society then yes a
large number of people will be
disadvantaged then we'll will notice it
right so so my sense is if everybody had
the tools to function in a meritocracy
then there'd be jockeying for position
well also if you if you regarded if in
order to do that you would need to widen
the array of things that we regarded as
being
worth having sure and actually frankly
you would want
also to forbid in some way i don't mean
necessarily legally forbid but maybe
disincentivize the production of all
kinds of things that are profitable that
are destructive
uh we get into the preto distribution
issue don't we
exactly um which
i understand i'm not going to try this
on you because you've got to tell me
this but i understand it in in nature is
is
the most recognized force in the in the
things in the forest that grow
up grow up tall
and the things that can't grow in their
shade don't
well i mean i'm not sure exactly what
you're getting at the only reason trees
are tall
is there in a competition for light
there are obviously lots of things that
are built
not to need canopy levels of light and
compete and
play some of those same games down near
the ground
you're drawing a connection i don't yet
see
um i'm trying to i understand in a range
of
certainly some uh um aspects of
your area of specialism that
the the problem of the curve that just
oh yeah
goes up well but so all right
so this is exactly what i think uh
you know as a liberal this is sort of
our job is to figure out what actually
could be achieved and one thing i would
say is we have a system
in which truly bad luck right that is to
say misfortune that does not arise from
bad decision-making
can ruin you that's very bad from the
point of meritocracy you want to protect
people
from bad luck you want to push it out
you want to make sure that the
the bottom part of the curve is softened
i want to make sure that a you are safe
to gamble in ways that are smart in
other words if you're
gambling on an idea uh
stands a chance of greatly improving
human well-being and it doesn't work
out but there was no way to know that
ahead of time i don't want you ruined
over it i want you protected it doesn't
mean i want you to profit from it
but the point is if bad decision-making
results in misfortune
and good decision-making results in
profit
then we evolve very quickly to a state
in which we
generate more well-being so protecting
people from bad luck is essential
right and making sure that people don't
freeze each other out of opportunity
so you know yes this never-ending battle
over education in the u.s
really comes down to people preventing
other people's children from getting
well educated
i have to say with with the with one
caveat which is so few people in this
country are well educated
i mean it's astonishing it's because
they go to school
yeah yeah i mean it's you know it's it's
it's another version of the
burrito issue which is you the
well-educated here are really
terrifically educated albeit sometimes
with appalling ideas at the margins
um but the um the majority seem to me
i mean the schooling system here the
university system
seems to have so woefully let down the
public
so so that's that's the connection i
want to draw is
to me i actually don't have
the sense of wanting to see uh
antifa or taunting the cops
beaten right maybe i just don't allow
myself to even have the thought
i actually feel like you know what
we really did [ __ ] up and we harmed a
huge number of people so that they do
not have the tools to function in the
system
that we uh leave open
and that that is actually that's a a
problem that you cannot solve
in less than a generation yeah there's
there's two things that are too specific
but there are two things that need
um uh opening out there please
one is what [ __ ] up is
and the second is who we are
right and when people say we
did this or we didn't do that the quest
is
is the first person plural actually the
right
one here because a lot of people didn't
do that
and were not sorry it happened in spite
of them
and in often against their wishes
so the we didn't do this in the case of
america obviously we
america the nation does have to bear
some responsibility as any nation does
but in many cases in this country as in
all countries what has gone wrong has
gone wrong because specific
actors decided to go the wrong route
i agree with this and you know
i i believe in the tension you are
describing but i also know
that it's some there's a
higher level truth of what we are
biologically and then there is some
reality that we have not yet gotten good
at integrating with it
right so um you know
i'm a jew my ancestors came
from europe uh in the 20th century
somehow i am an american
tied back to george washington right yes
my ancestors were somewhere else when
george washington was doing his thing
and yet
by virtue of the fact that i am a
citizen of this country and a believer
in it right
i actually have picked up you know the
george washington
and you know the martin luther king and
all of these things they actually become
part of what i am and maybe even the
more important part
and so the question is you know am
i responsible for the miseducation of
these people
no you know i've actually dedicated a
large fraction of my life to educating
people
well and i did it well on the other hand
is there a we
and did we [ __ ] up we [ __ ] up
we we allowed
and you know i don't think there's more
i could have done
no but i still feel the responsibility
for a society that has allowed i mean
you know i feel it not just with respect
to the
you know the people who were given
cruddy tools that now don't arm them for
the meritocracy that we insist they
should be competing in
but i also you know i'm watching the
homelessness population the homeless
population
grow and i know that a lot of these
people for they for a homeless
population to grow at the rate that it
is growing
those people weren't homeless some of
them were but yes
many of these people have gone from
having the ability to house themselves
to not having it
and what you know we have allowed that
to happen
um well again i mean
not to want to play the conservative
card too much back at you but
um one thing that oversized people on
everyone's mind is
is there a scenario that you can imagine
in which the person does actually
deserve to be on the streets
no no um this is a problem isn't it it's
the same thing
as the portions of the left i'm not
saying you
find it very hard to see what scenario
leads anyone to be in prison
well and it's something on the same
trajectory of thought
which is that i i don't think that
homelessness per se can ever be stopped
because i think that for instance
there will be some people who
actually i mean again it's impossible to
tell exactly what proportion there will
be a portion of people who want that
i've noticed that in san francisco and
elsewhere by the way i mean there are
some people who seem to
want to live on the streets there's a
very it's a
small proportion perhaps but a voluntary
street dwelling population might might
be something you you can't eradicate
what you want to eradicate is the people
who fell through
through through layer after layer after
layer of the society and
absolutely do not want to be there but
as with um as with prison as with other
things in our society where an
individual ends up in a catastrophic
situation
there does have to be some understanding
of
not not always assuming that it was
society that caused the thing to happen
because i mean this is let me give you
an example of the example
it's obvious in american society there's
a debate over incarceration that has
been going along
for a long time in incarceration rates
particularly over uh in
[Music]
breaking down by racial origin and one
of the answers that people have come to
on this i think
actually it's a pretty good place to
contest um
is is over incarceration rates of black
particularly male americans over
relatively low level drug issues
um dealing in small amounts of marijuana
what do you do in
large amounts of marijuana and all of
the comparisons i mean
this is this is what we were going back
to earlier
about the distribution of opportunity
and much more in society which is that
that is it's a good place to contest
this um it does seem unfair to people
and i think and i would share this that
that somebody whatever the racial origin
has their entire life
affected disenfranchised future job
opportunities forever
taken from them for what could be seen
as a relatively minor offense
and people leaning on this seem to me to
be leaning on something which is
it is reasonable it's a reasonable
concern the problem is
that those same people will not allow
themselves to say
what is the thing that means yes you
should be banged up
you should have future opportunities
taken away from you because what you've
done is
deeply harmful to everyone else in
society and the problem is is these
people
they say mainly a leftist problem cannot
do that bit
yeah and and that's the same thing with
it
and this is you know the the right can
be heartless
at times but there are times where a
form of heartlessness is necessary
if somebody is determined to do a thing
and does it again and again you cannot
then
say that we as a society let them down
no that person's responsible they have
to pay
yeah oh i totally agree question you
asked me was whether anybody deserves to
be homeless
right do people deserve to be in prison
many do
um the so
i'm not sure by the way i'm not sure
that i think anyone deserves to be
homeless
right but i'm saying the situation that
emerges that means that having some
people
will screw up again and again and again
and some people
we present it only in terms of they
haven't got the help they need
that is a very reasonable way to present
it but as
you know we all know there are people
who every single opportunity you give
them
they they they fall through well okay
you've got two categories i'd say there
are three categories right
you've got a category of people who
given enough functional structure would
be productive and decent and have fallen
through the cracks because there's no
safety net right then you have people
who
meet your description who given every
opportunity
can't pull it together but not
necessarily because
they want it that way they may be badly
damaged
and just incapable of uh you know doing
the kinds of things that would
that would solve the problem and then
you've got a
undoubtedly a category of people and i
don't know how big it is but a category
of people
who just suck and aren't interested in
participating in society
and you know i would argue
homelessness is not a right answer
in any of those three categories in part
not just because of the people involved
the first two categories i would
argue deserve our compassion right
the third category i don't know that
they deserve our compassion
but is it good for society to have
homeless people
it is not and so you have to provide
some
reasonable alternative but you also have
to make sure that that third
category whatever number they are do not
end up confusing and confounding the
rest of society
so 100 this is
it well you know it's a parent's dilemma
again it's it's it's
that at some point
it cannot be extrapolated out onto
everybody else when one person has
behaved in a certain way for which they
have to pay
total and with respect to the prison
side of the equation
i would say i think it is insane that we
do not distinguish
between um at the very least
sociopaths and maybe i mean psychopaths
in this case
and other criminals right and and so
it's
because the criminal one is in some ways
easier but i mean
going back to this thing there's
protests in portland the other night
because of
i gather sparked by the fact that a
family
who happened to be black um stopped
paying their rent some time ago
the landlord wants to evict them because
they haven't been paying their rent and
they say racism
and now people are campaigning for this
family to stay in
in the home the family itself says that
when you say they they say so yes as i
understand it
the people who live in the house say it
because of racism
i would venture as an outsider adventure
it's highly unlikely that
racism is the cause of the landlord
wanting to evict them and that it's more
likely that the landlord wants to be
paid for
right leasing his house to a to anybody
whatever their skin color i don't know
maybe we found a white supremacist
landlord in portland it's a
strange place for white supremacists to
try to earn their keep or whatever
um but but in this situation
every mechanism of the site and this
isn't just important every mechanism
of the society is in favor of the family
who is not paying the rent right very
very little and i'm not going to say
porn is an extreme example
but in general outside very little of
society
looks to the landlord who is losing
money
and thinks that we should pity them and
that's because
our societal ethic again it starts in a
good place it just doesn't know where
the hell to stop
favors the person who appears to be the
underdog over the person who
is perceived to have privilege and we
have become
wildly intolerant of
and unsympathetic with anybody perceived
to have privilege
and wildly over sympathetic with anybody
who can be claimed to be in any way an
oppressed group even if
they are allegedly oppressed because
there's something they haven't been
doing
which they should have done that was the
deal right
well so in this case i would just say um
a if you extrapolate and this is the
thing i think
in some sense americans are worse at at
the moment is extrapolating
but if you extrapolate from well we
can't very
well evict these people for not paying
because
it doesn't matter what follows the
because once you set
that in motion the point is what you've
done is
invalidated a system that houses people
without suggesting a replacement for it
so it's insane right it's just simply
unstable
now i will say as a
biologist who has spent a great deal of
time
working on and thinking about human
beings
i actually believe that there is
something deep to the idea
that the differences in well-being
that we see distributed in a non-random
way
uh between races
is a consequence of structural
features of history right echoing into
the present now again i
don't know this to be true for sure i
don't
you know it's something that remains to
be demonstrated but
i do think societally speaking we have
to leave that possibility
open until it has been disproven yes and
so if that if it is the case
that um a well-functioning
liberal society that protected people
from bad luck
provided people with tools that allowed
them to avail themselves
of the opportunities in the meritocracy
and incentivize them to do so
right if that's sort of the minimal
criteria that we would actually
find that many of the problems that are
motivating a lot of this
insanity would evaporate now they
wouldn't go
you know you wouldn't get total equality
you'd get a distribution of well-being
that
based on how hard different people work
and various other things but the
unfairness in the system would be
randomized
and so in a sense i think we have
and you know let's go back to your
example um
about we know or we
at least have excellent reason to think
that there is an important
racial inequality that has caused a
large number of black men to be
incarcerated for something that most of
us don't think
is even worthy of being criminalized
right the distribution of pot okay
you and i have no disagreement about
that well it might have
i'm not for decriminalization oh you're
not
i mean i i don't i believe in i mean
it's actually something i haven't
studied in an enormous amount but i i
actually don't think that
i think it's another layer of the
catastrophe of the society that on top
of everything else you decide this is a
great time to legalize pop part
i mean i don't think that people should
be should be punished for its
possession and i think this is roughly
my view it's not not a particular
totally evolved view i certainly don't
think people should be punished for the
possession of marijuana yeah
um i'm i don't think a society should
encourage
by legalizing its use because i think
that it does
a lot of damage once it gets going
interesting so here's here's what i
would say as somebody who used to smoke
a lot of pot
i haven't smoked it in a long time um i
gave myself an allergy actually but um
yeah i damaged my lungs and gave myself
an allergy yeah wow that's a lot
it was a lot wow i really i didn't do
the stuff but here's the thing okay
this was this was quite a long time ago
and pot wasn't i took that
yeah it wasn't nearly so strong a drug
it was a pretty minor phenomenon people
weren't
smoking the varieties that give them
psychosis and much more
right exactly and so what happened to
pot was that it actually
the thc got concentrated because the
criminal penalties tracked the weight
that you were trafficking in so the
stronger that the individual
quantity was the less the penalty for
trafficking a certain amount of
effect right so anyway we've created a
very powerful drug out of something that
wasn't very powerful
and you know again i question what we is
there but yes okay
our collective societal action
created a very powerful drug
out of marijuana which wasn't very
powerful to begin with and so
in the case of the ancestral the
pot we used to smoke ditchweed whatever
it was right
um it uh
i think actually on balance might be a
lot less dangerous
from the point of view of societal harms
than for example alcohol and that in
effect
criminalizing it meant people spend a
lot more time drunk i mean yeah i i know
the argument
i might just all the problems that
alcohol can cause and all the pleasures
it can bring
um it's
it's sub-optimal for society to have
many things like that in the circulation
system because um and i i don't find
it persuasive when people say that uh
that legalizing marijuana in california
or anywhere else
um is desirable because some people
drink beer
and i just add one other thing which is
again the state of somewhere like san
francisco
it's visible to an outsider that
marijuana legalization layered on top of
everything else
has not improved the society
i don't know how you would know oh i
mean things like every time i've visited
i mean the last time i was there
there were huge adverts everywhere for a
new company
which would deliver marijuana to your
door and i remember just thinking yeah
that's clearly the thing
this needs most is easier access so you
don't even have to leave your house to
get your
stash yeah um i actually i'm actually
i'm i do feel
sort of strongly instinctively about
this one again some people smoke pot i i
don't have a particular problem with it
i don't people want people to go to
prison for it
yeah but my god on a social level do i
not want them to do it around me
okay because they all become boring and
i think it's selfish
i don't think it makes them funnier or
more interesting or more insightful i
think it dulls their brain there's some
process of almost like retardation that
it seems to have on a lot of people
that goes on when they're not on it
yep and and i'd rather have a society of
sort of alert
and thinking people who who weren't
first of all weren't you know [ __ ]
from things they could do and think and
feel
and and and contribute through
again i mean come back i don't if people
want to do it
and it's available then sure i just
wouldn't encourage it
all right so okay i take your point and
again uh i
think we're talking about don't have to
get caught on marriage old different
beast than we used to be talking about
so okay you know
um you know let's leave it aside if we
agree
that there's some problem in which
society has uh not only penalized people
for
the relatively trivial offense of
uh having pot but done so in a
wildly unequal way um that has
then that would be wrong and it really
needing to be corrected right but here
would be my point
okay so you take a lot of black men for
a relatively trivial offense
and you lock them up this has an
automatic consequence that
um creates a much larger problem right
as bad a problem as that is right
removing people's freedom is a very
serious thing and doing some doing it
over something trivial is obviously
a uh an illiberal thing to do
but if you take a large number of men
out of a population then you
sure undermine the bargaining position
of women
in child rearing which results in women
raising children alone
yes can i cut in there sure sorry but
there's another thing
we are quite good at going over the
the effect that incarceration rates have
on
causing fatherless children
in america yep
my fear is that this is the conversation
i think that conversation should be had
i'm not by any means against it
this is i sometimes worry that some
things
like that come up because it's the
easiest conversation to have
i never hear it oh it's written about
pretty widely here isn't it
uh uh it's possible i've just missed it
but i keep raising it
and i get all the time among other
magazines is about a lot of pieces about
this
maybe we're not talking about the same
thing or maybe i'm unaware of what
they've written
what what do you think the argument is
that you see regularly portrayed
uh i mean i'm not not a particular fan
of his but tanya easy coats and others
have written the length on the way in
which incarceration has affected the
american
black family oh no no okay that is a
very common conversation right i'm
talking about something
um basically a
a biological argument sorry right
about mating systems and the predictable
effect
of creating an imbalance between the
numbers of males and females
and so you know situations like china
portions of china where there aren't
china is a very interesting paradoxical
violation of a biological principle
which says
right for very different reasons um but
anyway my point is just simply
we know that black men have been
incarcerated
uh at a high rate we can argue about why
that is but part of it seems to be
unfair and on the basis
of uh marijuana offenses for example
yeah part of it the consequence of that
is to create single-parent homes
and single-parent homes are almost
certain to produce
offspring who are less well-positioned
because they just have a lot less
parent effort available let me come back
to the i
the problem is again this is a part of a
conversation that's
relatively easy to have whether it's had
often or not i don't know
it's relatively easy to have it the
harder conversation
again it comes back to something like
the left right tussle is
what about all the people who do that
and has no relation to incarceration
rates marijuana possession or anything
else i.e
people who choose or just happen to
father children with people they have no
intention of staying with and leave and
leave another family being brought up
with a fatherless
situation my point there is
repeatedly a risk in our societies that
we address the
allegedly most difficult to address
thing
whilst actually leaving the really hard
to address
things completely unaddressed and that's
unaddressed because we come back to this
thing
it's easier to address whatever
percentage of whatever percent i would
say that
i i have to remind myself the stats on
this that
fatherless household are not primarily
in america caused because the father is
in
in jail for marijuana possession okay
right
so i want to clear this up a i totally
agree with what you're saying and
um you may or may not realize that this
is something heather and i have talked
about extensively we are
yes so there is something very troubling
going on
and i think it comes out of frankly
sexual liberalism
right which resulted in yes a crisis of
people producing offspring that they
didn't intend
to to care for so that is a part of the
discussion but
none of which is answered by sexual
illiberalism may we add
right yes exactly exactly so there's
some new conversation that has to happen
that basically
the fact of birth control sets something
in motion the consequences of which were
not well anticipated absolutely
so such a short way into it that right
so it's about time we had a good
conversation about that but i want to
make the point
i am not arguing that somebody's father
needs to be in jail in order for a
single-parent household to have been
created what i'm arguing
is the following thing men
are programmed for two reproductive
strategies
okay one of them involves investment in
offspring
and in that mode men are very much like
women in the sense that they are very
choosy and very careful with whom they
reproduce because
anyway it's a lifetime of investment the
other reproductive mode involves no
investment
the children are still needy and the
mothers raised them so my point is
given men programmed for both of these
possibilities
men find the idea of sex without
commitment
nearly irresistible and so what that
means is if you have a community
in which there are not enough men men
are in demand
there are lots of women willing the
point is it's very hard to nail
any of them down right and so the point
is how much
fatherlessness in the black community is
the result
of a simple demographic uh
uh lack of men available for
marriage right by the way can i say
do you see any uh um this i mean it
obviously must be replicated in other
communities as well
well you would see it in various places
that anything that eliminates men
would be likely to produce this unless
you had
cultural provisions that prevented it
yes
right um shame mechanisms exactly shame
mechanisms
that could be uh you know religious in
nature for example
um but
all this is to say we have
consequences we have a complex system we
have inequalities of various kinds
we have an uncertain assertion that
maybe
actually people given the same tools are
roughly equally capable
and that what we're seeing is the echo
of the fact that there was never a
moment when everybody was at the
starting line
at the same time right people start from
different places with different baggage
based on how they arrive in the
population
and that in effect we are i would argue
i believe we are dealing with the
downstream consequences of the fact that
we never
equalized things nor could we have but
that in some sense
that's the puzzle to be solved now if
you did that
and you found that there was residual
inequality left over
that would tell you you had a different
problem but until you've done that
imagining that the inequality and i
don't mean inequality in
wealth i mean inequality of capacity to
compete
right until you've equalized things
enough that we've run that experiment
then we're in this very cruel
predicament
of society blaming people for their
failures when we actually don't know
to what extent they are responding to
the tools they've been given yeah we
don't know and it's very hard to see a
scenario in which we could know
that's one of the problems i have with
this i mean
one of the reasons why the right is not
so keen on the whole equality argument
is the unmeasurability of the factors
we're talking about
totally i mean by the way i think
there's lots of things in our society at
the moment which
fall in where we have the same
unknowability problem
one that um is very much on my mind at
the moment
is mental illness which is on
everybody's minds
and which seems to me suffers from some
problem in this area
where we have compassion for
anybody with mental illness quite
rightly
it exists we know
but we also don't know where the
boundaries are for instance of people
who simply claim
an element of it in order to gain
something else
there is no knowing mechanism in society
there are doctors i speak to who say
we can tell when there are people who
are after a diagnosis of something that
will help them
i mean this of course in a cynical right
helping them
doctors tell me you know there are
certain things people would quite like
to be diagnosed
with that are actually if you did have
them you you did not want to have them
for example bipolar bipolar i mean oh
the number of people who
who appear to be almost proud of or
seeking of a diagnosis of being bipolar
because
they see there as being certain gains to
be made from it
nobody with bipolar problems would want
it
yeah but you can tell something is up
and again dr friends i speak to say is
because
um there are things that clearly people
don't want
nobody wants to go out on a date with
somebody and boasts that they're a
schizophrenic
right i i actually i've i've
noticed the same thing that there are
certain conditions that people
that apparently carry no stigma and
in fact the opposite in a way right i
kind of not always but in certain
situations and by the way
you know it's just threats again none of
this is by any means to
condemn or criticize people who actually
do have you know
serious conditions which seriously
affect their lives but we all know that
there are people who
who do want that we see them and we
experience it particularly when
people are growing up yeah that they
want to have
certain things in order to single them
out and make them special and give them
better treatment
they're better to be given certain
leeway by society
we don't have mechanisms in place to
deal with this
we and for something which for instance
in the british government a couple years
ago said
they wanted to treat physical mental
illness in with
the same dedication as physical illness
if you haven't worked out what the
boundaries are of mental illness in your
society
you've just allowed a massive problem to
erupt
because there's no delineation of right
you create a certain amount of
ambiguity between people who are
genuinely suffering and people who would
like to suffer because they'd like the
things that they believe accrue to
people who've suffered yeah it's uh
psychological munchausens or something
right and i i mean this is this the all
of these things do come together
i think i i joked to you when we were
having dinner with heather last night
that the
um i had wondered on arriving in
portland whether or not the water was
safe to drink
um there does appear to be something in
it um
that causes the growing of pink hair the
um
um um the masculinization of women and
the feminism
feminization of men yes um
causing me to go grey you got
[Laughter]
yeah but i mean does it you do wonder
um when the society has as many deranged
people in it
and as many people who believe they're
involved in some weird gender boundary
mellifluous
transgression and much more i mean again
to an outsider this stuff is obvious
here
you have an awful lot of people who i
mean
again roaming the streets who clearly
should be in
in places where they're being looked
after for mental problems
clearly you've got a problem with that
and you have a lot of people who are
clearly
operating in society who have a range of
um less severe but low level
um mental disorders yep who believe that
they
are and again this isn't to say that
trans doesn't exist as i say in manners
of crowds clearly something is going on
here we just know almost nothing about
it
but we also have people who are
pretending that they're trans in order
to gain attention and win the hierarchy
game of the year because weirdly
they think that in the intersectional
olympics to be gender fluid
is something that will make you win or
give you the megaphone that evening
and all of these things are going on
simultaneously and
and again a conservative critique of
that would be
because you didn't set up any boundaries
oh you didn't you didn't
chart any of this it was not in your
interests to be regulars it was not in
your interests
to pinpoint to people when they had
personally screwed up
nobody in this in the social system was
willing to say
shut up go and do your work nobody was
willing to say
you failed because you deserve to fail
because you're a reprehensible and
selfish figure
nobody was willing to do any of these
things and so you just have this
like literally a girl the other night in
a pink jumpsuit
screaming at the police and hurling
things hoping to be arrested
she's like we're there
so i think we are
we're in a position to converge here
because
um first of all let's just say i don't
think it's in the water in any literal
sense i know you're speaking
metaphorically i am speaking
metaphorically
that's a good thing to clear up just in
case well let's put it this way
from my perspective i think we've got
the same puzzle across
all of civilization which is
you have a huge number of people who are
sick yeah
psychologically physically
socially right and you don't know why
and you're busy telling me that all of
these things are safe you don't know if
they're safe
you know that they don't kill you
outright if you ingest them but you
don't know that they're not
long-term harmful and so the point is
we've got a lot of things causing
pathology
and we don't know what they are and
that's a very dangerous situation and it
should start a very
serious adult conversation about how you
deal with
things that cause pathology that you
can't identify in a complex
society where we keep inventing new
stuff and releasing it assuming it's
fine
yeah but um what i want to get
is this the situation you're describing
i
i don't agree i don't disagree with you
right we didn't set limits
we are we got exactly what we ordered in
effect right we set up a system
that was guaranteed to cause this kind
of dysfunction
and then we got this kind of dysfunction
we scratch our heads over it and that's
absurd
what we should have the way you do deal
with the problems that we've been
talking about without being able to run
the test
about what causes what is you set up a
mechanism
that protects people we don't want
people falling off the bottom of the
ladder
we don't want people rewarded for
hanging out at the bottom of the lab
right we want people incentivized to
solve their own problems we want them to
seek competence rather than incompetence
but we want to protect everyone i would
assume
from falling off the bottom and becoming
a burden to society on the street
right and then you want to arm people
with high quality tools for
making the most of life if you had a
system in which you protect people from
falling off the bottom
you arm everybody with high quality
tools
for making something of your life and
then
you allow inequality to drive people to
strive
right that i believe solves the problem
by virtue
of the fact that um
people have a very good reason then
to achieve right and that good reason to
achieve is what drives people away from
the kind of incompetence that you're
describing
yes do you think that's achievable
um again i think the big problem
is that we are talking about a problem
we have an immediate problem
like a it's october of 2020
and the clock is ticking and we're
talking about
what to do next week we have that time
scale of problem
and the solution we are talking about um
is if we started tomorrow it's still
going to be a generation
yeah yeah yeah so um let me add
offer alternative which is um
that thing of people falling off the
bottom when i said earlier you know
should any does anyone deserve to be
homeless what i'm trying to get at is
um society cannot
rack itself endlessly over the tiny
number of people who actually
fall through their own volition right
okay
we cannot be endlessly empathetic with
those who have been given every
opportunity and still
fall and one of the reasons is and i
mean this is a very again it's a very
ugly very unpleasant thing to say
perhaps is
that knowing that that is possible is
one of the things that keeps everyone
else
running well so
see citing that i mean i have this
instinct always with the
homeless i'm by no means heartless on
this issue but
you know you i i you know it depends
what your state in life
is but i certainly have times in my life
where i see somebody who's begging and i
think
could be me could be me and that's a
good instinct to have for lots of
reasons one is it gives you
sympathy with the person in question and
the other thing is it reminds you to
work
and run yes now the reason i say this is
because
and you're not going to like on your
local visitors are not going to like
this but
portland may be that example that the
rest of the world
needs to run and work
and do a lot of other things to stop
this being replicated and to that extent
those who would like to play the left
right and indeed media reporting cards
on this
are doing it i think for that reason to
give them a
most plausible steel man analysis of it
i suspect that some left wingers
including the
the far leftists in this region don't
like
accurate reporting of the extremes to
which their people are going
because they intuit that what is
happening is the rest of the country is
saying
we would like that lesson to become even
clearer
they might not be wrong on that i don't
doubt at all that there are a lot of
people on the american right
who would like to see portland burn to
the ground in order for it to be a
lesson for everybody else i don't doubt
that
i don't i don't know how common place
that is i don't think one could measure
it
but equally there are people of the left
who don't want any of what's going on
here to get out precisely because they
realize
that the lesson that people will take
from here might be the
opposite lesson to the one that they
hoped this place would
would be speaking to the nation at this
point in its history
and that is a that is a very reasonable
uh
uh explanation for why this place
has become such an epicenter of a much
bigger debate
because one group of people thought this
was going to be nirvana and nirvana
stinks and they intuit that
perhaps and another side
wants portland to fail because it wants
the rest of us to see how
and why it's failed and make sure we
don't replay the lessons
so i agree that this is part of the
dynamic and i think
you know it's um
this is unavoidably for my family a
personal tragedy because you know we
moved to portland because
in many ways it is an amazing city with
great promise and to watch it fail in
this way it's a beautiful city and
beautiful nature around you and
it has the potential to be marvelous if
only it had
you know i like its idealism right i
don't mean the
antifa insanity in the streets i mean
the idealism of your average
portland homeowner business owner right
i like what they're striving for i like
what they want but i want
the restraining force that causes it to
be you know
deployed in some reasonable way um
and that is not happening here
um i do want to
i i accept the pushback that you've just
delivered about portland's cautionary
tale
for liberals and i think it is that
um i want to deliver the other side of
that argument though
there is part of what is taking place
nationally
and in fact internationally that is the
result
of too much stinginess
on the part of the right in other words
i think that we had
a kind of post-cold war dividend that we
spent
very very stupidly and that we allowed
rent seeking
to uh to hoard opportunity that if it
had been broadly distributed
would have resulted in a much better
much
fairer much nicer society
and that in effect i
it's not that i want either side to be
held responsible for what happened
because i think it is actually
you know it's a it's a shakespearean
failure here that what we've got is each
side had its blind spot and the two
engaged in a kind of dance of death that
brought us
to this place and
the you know so there's a question about
what we can do about it immediately
and the answer is i don't know that
anybody knows the answer to that
no and on an individual level you know
for you and your family as for many
other
reasonable people in this place the uh
the calculus that has to happen by now
is is it worth hitting my head against a
wall
or is it worth getting out and
this is the conversation i had with lots
of people in california again from
across the political spectrum was
is this able to be improved or is it not
worth
you know um i quote in manchester crowd
somebody the wonderful american writer
wendell berry
who at one point um um in an essay from
the 80s or so
said something he said um you know we
all have to spend ourselves on something
and it's that's an interesting tipping
point in any society is
i will spend my time i will spend myself
on the attempt to turn around the city i
am in and from
and that i love and that has great
potential and then the moment when it's
perfectly clear that this is not a
useful way to spend
the limited energies we all do have in
our life
and that time to go well that's the
calibration
it is it is unavoidable and you know
i must say having seen this
in microcosm at evergreen and now seeing
it in portland
yes it's the same damn calculation which
was
you know heather and ice tried
everything we could think of
you know we were two of the most popular
professors evergreen had
i think ever heather was actually number
one
right you would have thought that we
could have brought reason
to that system and prevented it from
going over the edge
there came a point at which it became
utterly clear
that spend everything we had on the
puzzle wouldn't be
nearly enough to prevent the place from
imploding and that the only thing to do
was to get out yeah
right that became clear that same
i mean it's almost the identical
calculation
is now unfolding in portland and we
didn't you know sometimes our friends
give us a hard time why did you move to
portland
and the answer was actually the quality
of life here
was spectacular and much more affordable
than it was in many places so
you know we actually looked at 10
different cities that we might have
moved to and
we moved here because it was the best
but um
watching what it's doing now i have to
tell you my
my upbringing i was born in 1969 which
felt like as i was growing up it felt
like it was a long
time after the holocaust in world war ii
i now
as a an adult realize it was much closer
to those events than i had realized
and i cannot escape the question you
know
we always when i was growing up talked
about
people who had been living in eastern
europe jews who didn't
react fast enough and told themselves
that it would be okay
and you know that it would pass and then
it didn't
and you know i can't i don't know how to
convey
to people who are busy attacking
the foundations of logic of mathematics
science the enlightenment um
the idea of uh equality amongst
the races i don't know how to say to
these people
you are scaring the [ __ ] out of those of
us who know anything about history
because you sound an
awful lot like things that we have seen
and this doesn't end well
right absolutely but i also you know the
question i asked you earlier
where are the examples where people who
were headed this direction turned around
because they realized what they were up
to or some
properly moderate restraining force
caused them too the ordinary thing that
happens at this stage in a society is a
war
right very large numbers of people die
and people are reminded of one of the
forces of nature um
[Music]
saying that sounds catastrophic but
there's no way around it that that's
what um late empires
and um societies which have this number
of things this is they said that's what
happens and it requires that as a
and the problem about that is of course
is that it's both the mechanism that
sets things back on some other
trajectory and also the thing that kills
vast numbers of people you can't ever
wish for it
nobody's saying would occasionally meet
insane people who would
um this is this is why the
the the misunderstanding the what i
described
beginning the the wrong projection on
the wall
of things which you then walk war
against
is so important to correct and by and
and it has to be done at that micro
level and i mean maybe a lot of people
didn't realize when you realized heather
realized but that
if if you allow people to get away
with the subtle tiny misrepresentations
around the margins of the thing that is
being created
if you allow that to happen when it's
projected on the national wall
you'll know that you should have got it
right earlier
that's brilliant by the way um you're
this is
exactly how it works there are those of
us who are
sticklers for getting the fine detail
right and i think we often look absurd
to others because their point is just
generally yeah why didn't you just let
it go right absolutely and
the answer is because sooner or later
you're going to hit an
amplifier and when you amplify the
little
incorrect aspects of this you're going
to cause the whole thing
i've had this throughout my life and
noticed it among many friends and
colleagues and
that in different sectors this is this
is
perhaps unknowingly often the reason why
we are sticklers for detail
because like that we will not i mean the
most obvious one in america today is
like
why would you argue about the details i
was in new york the other the other week
and
you know we were talking about the
breona taylor case and and and things
and
and you know i came away from that
thinking
everyone had different views and
different claims but i came away from
that just thinking you know
why are we sicknesses it's because that
matters
because one narrative of it like the
george floyd casey
one narrative of it if you don't
get all the facts right will allow the
projection on the wall
to be the american police are allowed to
kill black people with impunity
and some of the people doing that will
have done it for short-term political
gain some will perfectly
you know that will be their estimation
of events including people whose
estimation of events is thus because
they have themselves suffered
at the hands of the law unfairly
themselves
the problem is you will create this next
generation which is clearly one of the
things you had at evergreen and clearly
one of the things that's going on in
portland
that actually believes the picture that
has been
played onto the wall in front of them
and at this stage
cannot be shifted from that unless it is
through
some monumental re
boot of the whole system which is only
imaginable
through a catastrophic event yes
although so a i will say i was
as a younger man i was a believer in the
idea
that um a catastrophic destruction of an
american city could
wake the population to what it wasn't
paying attention to i no longer believe
this i mean you know katrina among other
things revealed that
no that just wasn't the case anymore i
also think
that there's something about the
spectacularness of
what we see on our screens that has
caused us not to be able to detect when
something is so spectacular in the
outside world that it should immediately
grab our attention and we should
think very soberly about it so we're
we're sort of caught where people are
dealing as if their
beliefs and what they say don't have
consequence because
because of the narrative environment
we're in but
i did want to add one thing to your
portrayal i agree
one possible interpretation is
this is what people do war is the thing
that puts the brakes on it you can
descend into madness
disaster catastrophe it doesn't actually
be war doesn't have to be powerful
it could be genocide could be lots of
things but the point is societies
go crazy they hit bottom and then they
come back but i don't think that happens
here
and the reason i don't think that
happens here is because
the us isn't just any country yes yes
yes
this is 2020. yes the u.s plays a
special role
in the west well i know i mean i i live
in one of the outposts of the empire
exactly and so
whenever things go wrong in rome
right they um affect us in um
galicia they do and
the thing so that may be an ancient
pattern but the new pattern
is the technological context that we
live in and the fact that you know
this will be the first time you've had a
major reorientation like that
on a planet armed with nuclear weapons
for example
yes and all able to see everything in
real time and not agree on what we've
seen and much more
right and yes then you layer on to it
the
uh industrial strength scientifically
tuned propaganda
generators and we're talking we have to
stop ourselves
and without a precedent for how that
happens without hitting rock bottom
well that's that's why
the details are going to continue to
matter
and the individuals however small in
number they are
who care about the details must continue
to be seen to do well
you know this is why people admire you
and heather
it's why people admire the figures who
are willing to
get the details right
and i think if i have any hope in all
this and i always do have some hope
um it's that people re-learn
why some people were compelled to be
sticklers in this era
and that they were not
they were not being boringly pedantic
uh they were not narrow
in their vision but saw that
when the madness of the era trod on
their
areas and they said no you don't get to
do that
they were making the most important
fight that they could in the areas they
knew about
and that in case after case in recent
years that's what's going on
yes i must say at the moment um
it's possible that it's at the wrong
scale to even know whether that's
possible
but the overwhelming sense for heather
and me
was that
we were surprised that people actually
correctly registered that what happened
at evergreen
was this thing we are seeing more widely
and that we did say
we got it exactly right we were told at
the time we were overreacting or maybe
it was an extreme case or something
there's been wide acknowledgment that uh
we were seeing accurately and that the
warning was if anything
tamer than it might have been rather
than
uh an overreaction however
it seems to amount to nothing with
respect
to it's we're just going to repeat the
disaster and it's like
you get some kind of a prize for having
spotted the last one and correctly
diagnosed it
but there's no like okay well then what
do you think is happening now and what
do we do about it it's like
it's treated as a completely separate
phenomenon
at the level of what's going to happen
here when i think the answer is what's
going to happen here is what happened
there
except that when it happens at the scale
of major american cities
it's going to result in the loss of life
and limb and well-being and it is going
to place the nation
in terrible jeopardy
relative to its big bad antagonists in
the world
yes i think that's right um
um one
way in which all of this corrects itself
is by
america failing being seen to have
failed
and those who believed in other systems
to
be able to portray themselves as having
been vindicated
my own belief is that that's the worst
case scenario imaginable um
because people who didn't like the
american empire or the american era of
hegemony and dominance are going to love
the chinese one
this this is exactly it and here's the
thing
people don't understand that they are
that humans are themselves
the latest iteration in
an ancient evolutionary battle right
that until humans nobody can name or
understand is even taking place
right and the point is the chinese might
even be
more fit their system might be more fit
but it is pointless
yeah it's pointless because it does not
liberate the individuals to do the
things that humans are uniquely capable
of doing
and so the point is we have to win even
if their system is
more robust and fitter because it's
it has no purpose and absolutely you
know yes
no no a life dedicated to growth
in china right it's not alive
right you know i mean a yeast is a very
successful entity but we don't want to
become
yeast right
no right we don't want to do it and you
know frankly
if you know the west were to catch on in
such a way that the chinese were
liberated to be
freer and less efficient you know it
would be good for them
it might not be good for them in the
sense of their
you know long-term uh
growth as you put it but but it would be
good for them from the point of the
human part the part
that makes us different that part is
really the part struggling to survive
in this era and i think it's on the
ropes
it is on the ropes but as it always is
it always is um it's
uh not been on the ropes to this extent
in this place
for a long long time and
uh that's why it matters that's why the
city we're sitting in
name is known
it's why it matters it's why evergreen
mattered
it's uh it's why america matters
and um one can't be
too um adamant about this
that that screwing
this up or
claiming that if you bring it down
better things will emerge
are things that have to be stopped
um not just willed but stopped
by people who know what the stakes are
and that's why whatever
way through there is it involves people
of left and right
centrists boring though they may be and
much else
agreeing that the optimal conditions
may not be these but all of the rest
are infinitely worse including
the ones that are being propagated
by people in the name especially of
social justice
and equality and much more and
um we have to not be derailed by these
people
we have to stand up to them the american
public have to stand up to them
the american authorities have to stand
up to them
and you know the world only walks
in one direction in relation to america
which is towards it
[Music]
there is no mass movement to
sudan there is no mass movement to saudi
arabia
china does not have a massive
immigration problem of people wishing to
flee to it
the footfall speaks for itself it's a
very good point
it speaks for itself and the american
public and politicians should realize
whatever
direction they come from this is too big
a thing to screw up
and it's too big a thing
to get the details wrong
for the short term because america's
short term is the world's long term
that's
very very well said and i must say if i
can
just simply uh paraphrase
the implication here this is something i
have felt very
strongly for a very long time it is not
our right to screw this up
we americans there is an irony in the
belief in democracy
which is that democracy is about the
consent of the governed and because
the us plays a role in governing the
world many of those who are governed by
it whether they like it or not
have no vote here and so in a sense
we have to vote with the responsibility
to the rest of the world in mind and we
are doing a terrible job of it
yeah well you vote in what two weeks
so we'll see well let me ask you one
thing before we go
um you have traveled in the u.s now you
came
west from the east coast and then you
traveled up the west coast
landing here in portland
i don't know how to ask you this exactly
i'm
tuned into a bunch of conversations
amongst
some powerful and influential people i
know what i hear
you've now physically passed through
places where you will have participated
in many of these conversations in person
the elite how well do they understand
what's going on
how coherent do you think their response
to it is
i can't really say i mean i can only
dispute tiny parts of it
um uh i mean america is such a complex
country as you know it's so wide
it's so hard to it's so high so
infinitely interesting
because it's so hard to gauge it because
of the difference from state to state
place to place city to city and much
more so if
somebody says you know do you have your
ear to the ground in america you have to
be where
sure there's an awful lot of places to
put your ear too
um it's
it's it i can't really answer that i i
i'm struck by the number of people who
are now
thinking catastrophic thoughts and
coming to
emergency scenario planning
very struck on uh
in all the places i've been to so far
with the fact that that people for
instance are planning to
vote and then get out of the area they
live in
[Music]
um
it's it's it's just it's a terrible fate
for a country the one you're in
it's just a terrible horrible fate
because
nobody nobody
is wild about anyone
other than people who you wouldn't trust
to be wild
i mean um i feel embarrassed
for this country in some ways um
i'm embarrassed by those who are going
to vote for joe biden
as if in his fifth decade in politics
he's going to do something he didn't do
in the first
four well said of course
i think it's so preposterous all these
things you say you're gonna do but why
didn't you do them in 47 years
of this um i'm embarrassed for them
because i know their heart isn't in it
and and they're they're
doing something which is is transparent
to everybody
and i'm embarrassed for republicans
and others who have to pretend that
donald trump is lots of things he isn't
including somebody you can totally trust
um i'm embarrassed for them because
it seems to me i i've avoided writing
about trump pretty much for the last
four years partly because
everybody's got a view partly because
you can't change anyone's mind and
partly because it's so damn obvious
i mean i i can riff on him like
everybody else i mean you
want me to list his flaws i can do it
lying down
but we all can and um
and the the embarrassment to my mind for
republicans and say for trump voters
is that their man has been in for four
years
and although he is to some extent
capable of pulling big levers
he has no capacity
to effectively do things
he can do big things quite well on
occasion
um the trade war with china doesn't seem
to me to be something anyone else would
be able to do
and i think it's necessary um i think
that oh i mean things like the critical
race theory stuff is something probably
almost
well actually probably no other leader
would do it's just repeatedly with him
you have this thing but
but why don't you follow through with
things why don't you do things why
aren't you interested in detail why
can't you get anyone to work with you
um and much more and i'm embarrassed
from my
you know friends and contacts and and
and others who
who have to pretend that trump is
something he isn't just i'm embarrassed
for those with
the same problem on the other side um
i'm personally rather relieved i don't
have a vote in this election i'm pleased
to be one of the disenfranchised
on the remnants of the empire
so uh all right do you have a sense of
what's going to happen
i don't i mean like everyone i've got
different scenarios and the polls seem
to show that biden's going to win
and yes they seem to and they and and of
course then everyone says aha but they
seem to show that hillary was going to
win last time
oh and i've just got all the thoughts in
my head simultaneously i have no special
way of seeing through the fog and
i see odd things i've spoken to
surprising people who are going to vote
trump
who i would never expect it to do so
i've i've
seen rallies and gatherings in which
there seem to be
support for trump on a level that is not
replicated in the polls
um but i also think that america as
peggy noon and brilliantly wrote the
other week in the woolsey journal might
want
a return to normality and they think
that voting
rightly or wrongly they think that
voting biden would be some return to
normality from a reality tv show that
they've been forced to watch for four
years and they can't change the channel
on
um my own
views are always sort of beyond the
individual the ballot
and and on to the sort of the fate of
the nation and i wha
what what um what i find
um difficult to comprehend is
where what is the best and worst long
case scenario in
each outcome only knowing that the worst
case scenario is a contestation in
multiple jurisdictions and uh
just oh which is highly likely highly
likely
and that i mean um i spoke to
somebody the other day and i said that
my the absolute worst case scenarios i'm
sure you know is the um
is the reverse of the moonlight oscars
scenario you know the
the um the other year where the oscars i
mean obviously nobody watches it anymore
but um at the oscars they
gave the best picture to la la land oh
yeah
and then it turned out that they got it
wrong and it actually went to moonlight
this
black gay um movie that wasn't seen by
anyone other than the cast
and uh moonlight um fortunately
um was given the oscar and um
i remember the time watching that
thinking oh thank god it happened that
way
if they'd have taken the oscar from the
black gay movie and handed it over to
the boring whitey lala singing dancing
uh tedious movie uh there would have
been rioting in downtown within a few
hours
um so you said news in brief the next
day and the
english papers would have been shots
were heard you know
overnight and obviously the worst case
scenario for america in terms of
security is
that um the democrats uh um are thought
to have won
and then it turns out that trump won
right would you agree that's the
absolute worst case scenario well let's
put it this way the
the worst case scenario starts there yes
yeah yeah of course
all of this is only the day off oh yes
only this is the day after i'm sorry if
i
say any of this with sort of glee and
laughter because of course this is this
is
a country in your life i think um well
first of all i think
in some sense um anybody who's paying
attention to you
knows that uh you have an extraordinary
capacity
for uh gallows humor
um they know where your heart is and
they know you're not
rooting against us or um delighting in
our
our
torment so anyway yes i think there's no
danger no danger of you being
misinterpreted that way
all right well um i will make a
prediction
about the election we're going to lose
oh yeah and by we i mean the american
people yes yes
um yeah all right
this has been a great discussion um it
has been a
real pleasure to see you in person you
were the first guest of the podcast
remotely and now uh in this era where
everything is remote here you are
um i was just stressing a chilly and
windowed opened
right we have increased the volume of
this room to fight covid to an
incredible degree by
plugging this room into the outside
world
and turning on the fan so i don't think
either of us is sick with covet but
we've taken precautions
and uh in any case um very stimulating
discussion
i i really appreciate it um where should
people look for you
they should look for your most recent
book which is just updated the madness
of crowds are out in an updated edition
at the moment
uh just that this month and they can
find out
if you can find any bookshops um
the madness of crowds gender race and
identity is available there on amazon
on barnes noble on all of these
things and i'm also on twitter douglas k
murray where i actually
do post and otherwise um various
places in youtube various maniacs upload
interviews with me that they've
conducted against all the
better better judgments yes exactly and
i will say as i think i said in the
first podcast i did with you
um that i found the audio version of
your book particularly delightful
because you yourself read it
and uh you read it like no one else
could so it's great
i much recommend the audible version
yeah it's um i had a whale of a time
uh laughing almost every page and i had
to say to sound technicians not because
of my own jokes but because of the
madness what i'm talking about and the
crazy
crap that i have to recite from a range
of mad men and women
yep and now you've been to the epicenter
and now i've been to the epicenter and
i've
yep can't wait to leave
well that's a terrible thing to say
we don't call it leaving anymore we call
it fleeing
[Laughter]
all right well thanks everyone for
tuning in and uh
hopefully we will see you again soon you
bet
you